غياب الكهرباء والماء في الحرب مرادف
لمعاناه الاوكرانيين تقول سلطات كيف انهما
تعودان تدريجيا للمدن بعد الضربات
الصاروخيه الروسيه التي عطلت جزءا كبيرا
من قطاع الطاقه في البلاد تغرق اوديسا
وميكو لايف في الظلام بعد هجوم صاروخين
روسي في ما يقف سكان العاصمه كياف في
طوابير طويله للحصول على الماء والمشروبات
الدافئه من خيام الطوارئ ويصطف اخرون لجمع
مياه الشرب من نافوره
[موسيقى]
لذلك سيكون كل شيء على ما يرام وستبقى
اوكرانيا صامده تقول اوكرانيا ان روسيا
تستهدف البنيه التحتيه للطاقه وهي
استراتيجيه وصفها الحلفاء الغربيون انها
جريمه حرب مع حلول فصل الشتاء شنت روسيا
وبلا جديدا من الضربات الصاروخيه على
اجزاء كبيره من زابوريجيا وكياف والبيض ما
اجبر المدنيين على مواجهه انقطاع التيار
الكهربائي والعيش خلال درجات حراره منخفضه
ياتي القصف الروسي في وقت سوت البرلمان
الاوروبي باغلبيه ساحقه على اعتبار روسيا
دوله راعيه للارهاب